ACTION QUICKLY, BACK TO YOU.
>> Todd: UNBELIEVABLE VIDEO.
REPUBLICANS PREPPING THEIR
INVESTIGATION NOW THAT THEY
FLIPPED THE HOUSE, INCLUDING
PRESIDENT BIDEN'S BOTCHED
WITHDRAWAL FROM AFGHANISTAN AND
HIS SON'S BUSINESS DEALINGS.
>> ONE THING I KNOW IN
WASHINGTON, THEY DON'T HAND THE
GAVEL OUT IN SMALL, MEDIUM AND
LARGE, ONE SIZE WITH ABILITY TO
SUBPOENA AND HOLD GOVERNMENT
ACCOUNTABLE, SECURE THE BORDER,
FIGHT TO MAKE US
ENVELOPE-INDEPENDENT, GIVE
PARENTSES A SAY IN EDUCATION AND
LOOK AT WHAT THE DOJ AND DHS ARE
DOING AND OTHERS.
>> Carley: JIMMY FAILLA, JOINS
US NOW.
JIMMY.
>> Jimmy: HAPPY FLORIDA.
>> Carley: LET THE INVESTIGATION
BEGIN.
YOUR THOUGHTS?
>> Jimmy: STRONG THOUGHTS, I'VE
BEEN IN THE CASINO DRINKING AND
GAMBLING FOR A DAY AND A HALF, I
AM HUNTER BIDEN RIGHT NOW.
I HAVE NERVE PULLING THIS GUY
OUT, BUT I WILL, MY DAD IS NOT
DOING SHADY BUSINESS DEALS.
EVERYBODY SHOULD BE CONCERNED
ABOUT THIS, IF FOR NO OTHER
REASON OTHER THAN HUNTER BIDEN
CAN'T GET THIS MONEY IF HIS DAD
IS NOT VICE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES AT THE TIME.
NOBODY IN THE CONGLOMERATES OR
POWER COMPANIES WERE SITTING
AROUND IN THE BOARD MEETING, YOU
KNOW WHAT WE NEED TO DO?
A GUY GOT THROWN OUT OF CHATEAU
FOR DOING TOO MANY DRUGS AND THE
CIA HAD TO PAY HIS BILL.
I DON'T THINK THERE WAS A THING.
IF THERE IS SMOKE, THERE IS
FIRE, EITHER THAT OR ELIZABETH
WARREN SENDING A MESSAGE.
>> Todd: DO YOU THINK WE WILL
GET TO THE BOTTOM OR DO YOU
THINK THIS IS SMOKE WITHOUT THE
FIRE?
>> Jimmy: I DON'T KNOW THAT WE
WILL, SUCH AN EFFORT TO BURY THE
LAPTOP AND SEEM TO BE RUNNING
INTERFERENCE, PRETTY GOOD AT
RUNNING CLOCK AND WHAT PEOPLE
REFER TO AS THE DEEP STATE, I
DON'T KNOW A LOT ABOUT THE DEEP
STATE, DEEP DISH, MAYBE PIZZA.
I DON'T LIKE WHERE IT IS GOING,
I RESPECT THE REPUBLICAN --
LET'S GO, BOYS.
>> Carley: ART CAREER SHOULD NOT
BE OVERLOOKED.
>> Jimmy: $550,000 PER PAINTING,
IF YOU THINK THE PRICE WAS HIGH,
MEET THE GUY WHO DID THE
PAINTING.
>> Carley: GREAT FATHER-SON
MOMENT.
>> Todd: DEEP DISH, STAYING IN
CHICAGO, SEE WHAT I DID THERE?
MAYOR LORI LIGHTFOOT, PEOPLE ARE
NOT HAPPY WITHER HAD, BY PEOPLE,
I MEAN BIKERS, SHE ALLOWED
SECURITY DETAIL TO PARK IN A
BIKE LINE WHILE SHE WENT INSIDE
TO GET DONUTSES.
SHE WAS PRO-BIKE, WE NEED TO
KEEP BIKERS SAFE.
WHY DOES SHE SEEM TO BE CAUGHT
IN THE HEIGHT OF HYPOCRISY WHEN
SHE DOES ANYTHING?
>> Jimmy: THAT IS LORI
LIGHTFOOT'S WHOLE ETHOS.
DONUTS SOUND GREAT.
TYPICAL LORI LIGHTFOOT, NEVER
HAD REGARD FOR ANYBODY, BUT LORI
LIGHTFOOT.
REMEMBER SHE GOT CAUGHT GOING TO
GET A BLOW OUT, I GOT TO DO TV
HITS, SO DO I, LOOK AT MY FACE
ON TV.
THAT WHOLE THING.
>> Carley: THE MAYOR ALL, BUT
APOLOGIZED SAYING THEY SHOULDN'T
HAVE PARKED IN THE BIKE LANE
PERIOD.
MAYBE THEY BROKE THE LAW, ISN'T
IT ILLEGAL?
>> Todd: NOT IF YOU ARE THE
MAYOR SECURITY DETAIL.
>> Jimmy: WHAT IS FUNNY --
>> Carley: LIKE JAY WALKING.
>> Jimmy: WE ARE FOCUSING ON
THIS, CHICAGO IS OUT OF CONTROL,
SEAL TEAM SIX GOES TO GET
SCARED, BAD.
EVERYBODY NEEDS TO CLEAN UP
THEIR ACT.
>> Todd: RACHEL CAMPOS-DUFFY
LIKED THAT JOKE.
>> Jimmy: STOP IT.
>> Carley: BIKERS ARE VERY BOLD,
TALK ABOUT THAT, TOO.
THERE IS FLIP SIDE TO THIS.
>> Jimmy: I CAN'T STAND LORI
LIGHTFOOT, AS A CHICAGO, WE KNOW
BIKERS ARE MOST ARROGANT PEOPLE
IN THE WORLD.
GET OUT OF THE WAY, IDIOT,
IDIOT?
I'M NOT THE IDIOT, YOU ARE IN
SPAN DECKS IN COSTUME, IMAGINE
GOING OUT TO DINNER WITH AARON
BOONE, AND HE SHOWS UP IN HIS
UNIFORM, THOSE ARE BIKE GUYS.
>> Todd: YOU CONVINCED ME, THAT
IS MAGIC YOU YOU CAN GET WHEN
YOU WATCH JIMMY'S SET, IS YOUR
SET GOING TO BE DIFFERENT
TONIGHT?
>> Jimmy: WE'RE AT PATRIOT
AWARDS --
>> Carley: PREAWARD SHOW COMEDY
SHOW.
>> Jimmy: I'M THE PUMPER, I PUMP
EVERYBODY UP, I WILL SLIDE A
COUPLE JOKES AND SALUTE HEROES
AND HAVE A GOOD TIME.
>> Carley: 6:45?
STREAM ON FOX NATION.
>> Jimmy: YOU CAN'T COME ATTACK
THE COMEDIAN.
>> Todd: NEVER USE THAT WORD ON
OUR SHOW, CARLEY'S CHILD
INNOCENT  EARS.